i am
deep inside someone likes to build stuff
hardware software technology
uh etc i learned over the years that the
best way to build something is with a
kickass team around you and a business
around you
so i for me
it was very natural to evolve from a
technologist
to someone who can scale his thoughts
and ideas
with an amazing team and turn it into a
business that has scale and the
opportunity to go big so yes to me it
was natural
but that's my personal journey
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hello at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet emil
aurad the ceo of sisense amir is seisen
ceo and chairman of the board focusing
on infusing analytics and business
intelligence in every application and
every user amir has led startups to
become industry leaders with hundreds of
millions in revenue and multiple m a's
he is a serial entrepreneur specializing
in growing big data and cyber security
businesses with over 25 years of
experience as a leader in these fields
during his previous tenure at nice
actimize he grew the business 10x to a
200 million dollar revenue run rate
previously he was co-founder of sayoda
which he sold to rsa security
he lives in new york father of three
holds an mba from columbia university
and has been acknowledged as a top 50
sas ceo
all right amir orad welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from new york how
are you
doing well thank you
thank you so much for joining here amira
um
wow
an incredible journey i'm gonna get so
tired just from reading this incredible
uh journey that you're on but just you
know
basic highlights which and that just
simplify this incredible journey that
you have
from being the co-founder and executive
vice president of product and chief
marketing officer of sayota
acquired by rsa security for uh over a
hundred million dollars 145 million
dollars to be exact and then sea of nice
actimize uh with 200 million dollars of
revenue run rate and now ceo of sisense
talking about analytics and ai and
talking about this transition from cyber
to analytics and ai and and how they're
sort of converging if they're converging
and i'm excited to talk to you about
what it means to be a serial
entrepreneur in your mind and continuing
to work so freaking hard even though
you've done so much and and i want to
get into your brain with that so amir
thank you so much for joining me how are
you
i'm doing well thank you excited to be
here thank you who are you emil i just
said you know this the crazy shopping
list of things you've done but but who
in essence is amir rod
yeah i'm uh it's quite simple i'm uh
a geek
kind of deep inside i'm a geek that
played with computers since there was a
child
back then that was commodore 64 basic
assembly pascal cc plus plus journey
um that led me to
become i don't know today you'll call it
a hacker back then you call it a
whiz kid whatever you call it playing
with technology before it was uh
a common thing
using the internet when it was usenet
and gofer and whatever you call it back
then pbs's
that led me to be identified by 8200 in
israel and spent six years
building
really cutting-edge technology around
uh data cyber analytics security
and many other things
and i just have to say that
you know today a lot of people are
dealing with cyber but you were doing
that within the idf at a time where
cyber didn't really exist in the world
it was you know pretty much as as
internet was breaking out
this was 1994 1995. no one had a clue
what they were talking about this was
ahead of its time we created or put the
railroads
or the foundation for what today is
common in in you know every organization
out there both in terms of cyber and
interview of data and analytics
and again it was an opportunity of a
lifetime really i would
in a hot bit return to do it i spent six
years doing it
um
and you know close finishing a degree in
parallel because i kind of knew computer
science by then
uh and the day i left
this was uh the end of 1999 early 2000
there's only one thing you do as a
technologist in that time and that is
start a company so i became a co-founder
of a company called sayota that was
initially in the payments and anti-fraud
space and then became a cyber security
company
uh built an amazing technology for
authentication
every day michael you use
what we invented it's called risk-based
authentication it's what you use to log
into google or facebook or bank of
america
that is that you log in and you get a
text message saying this is a strange
activity put your code in here
and it's really a two-factor
authentication done dynamically based on
a risk profile using analytics
so it was a sas company cyber company
analytics company in the year 2000
before those things were a thing
and today everyone use them
spent seven years leading product
delivery
marketing and so on in that company
sold it to rsa security as you said for
over a hundred meal which back in the
day was probably like a unicorn these
days
and um
then i moved to my second startup i
joined it early on i was not a founder
but i mean i wanna
stop you for a second and ask
you mentioned that it was a trivial it's
almost a trivial thing that you go out
of and after the work that you've done
and start a company but you know i'm
trying to understand are you a geek are
you an entrepreneur you know today
you're leading almost a thousand people
maybe even more with sizes
it doesn't you know is it really was it
really a trivial decision to go and
start a company
uh
i am
deep inside someone likes to build stuff
hardware software technology
etc i learned over the years that the
best way to build something is with a
kickass team around you and a business
around you
so i for me
it was very natural to evolve from a
technologist
to someone who can scale his thoughts
and and ideas
with an amazing team and turn it into a
business that has scale and the
opportunity to go big so yes to me it
was natural
but that's my personal journey
and
that's why company number two i didn't
feel the need to be the founder i joined
an amazing team and built it to the next
level all the way to a 200 million
dollar
financial crime and risk management
company again using deep analytics to
make decisions this time not for
online security but for
fraud and money laundering and market
abuse and insider trading
that became part of nice system and it's
today the
the fastest growing
business within my system a very large
public company
so i spent eight nine years doing that
and you know getting to about a hundred
thousand people and it was exciting it
was really amazing
uh to do
and then after a short break i started
number three which is by the way the
number of my kids i have as many kids
have startups by now three kids three
startups
and i joined sisense and the reason i
joined sisens was that i built my own
analytics
and ai technology
at company number one and company number
two
and when i met the sites in steam
i realized here we can build the
platform that lets anyone
build analytics in their products in an
easy way and embed them in their
products and business
so i joined scissors early on that was
seven years ago it was a single digit
revenue company
where today we just announced over 140
million revenue company
um
and working with the likes or empowering
the likes of
you know the tech companies of uipath or
uber or
seismic and outreach all the way to big
corporations like nasdaq and ge
and instacart etc
and the beauty is that we are giving
those companies similar technology that
once upon a time i had to build myself
and now someone can buy a platform and
inject it in the cloud on top of their
existing product or service for a
building so to me it was a natural
progression and evolution
uh it's kind of the cyber and security
markets and the analytics markets
collided
uh into building a platform that can
help others do the same
and here we are the 20 years after
i'm curious to know where we'll be from
the the fourth startup the fourth kid
but but i'll leave that for for post
recording
three startups is also a lot uh i i have
to ask you know you're starting what you
first of all you said something that was
really interesting to me you said you
know that you realize that the the power
the power that you have is to take your
geekiness and scale it with a team of
kick-ass engineers
right
that mindset
of ego aside and taking that same you
know intrinsic geekiness and motivation
but now empowering a team of really
great people to build that with
you where did you learn that was that
the idf was that in your first startup
no it started already in the idf the
realization
that having a great idea
and writing code by yourself
is not the
the
best way to achieve success and it
depends how you define success if you
count the lines of code you write then
you need to be a developer for life
if you look at it as turning
a whiteboard
image diagram into a
established
successful highly used
piece of technology then it doesn't
matter who writes the code what matters
is that you translate an idea into
a working technology and then when you
think about the technology the only way
to get people to use it and turn it from
a working technology to something that
is vastly used is to build a business
around it so those were kind of the
thoughts
and that was my personal evolution from
a developer to an r d leader to a
product manager
then go to market with sales and
marketing
because end of day write beautiful code
that sits on your hard drive and is not
used by anyone
doesn't matter
at least to me doesn't matter it's it's
uh
it's not enough
and so that's that was my personal
evolution and also learning over time
i actually don't care whose idea is it
as long as i'm in love with it
it's as much as it is mine as someone
else
so that was also kind of a maturity
curve i went through uh in my life
a long time ago it seems you've already
realized that you know data is eating
the world
and that make data-driven decisions uh
go hand-in-hand with the cyber security
space
and you're you're managing that you've
built these
sectors within you know as prominent
parts of your of your previous
businesses and now you've joined you're
the third company size sense that is
that is you know world leader in this
field where do you how do you see these
two industries converging
oh to me it's very very clear the era
of and i recall it i've been there of
writing hard-coded
anti-virus
signatures and firewall rules
and ports opening and closing
and watching logs coming out from
various systems that era
is gone
not because of technology innovation
that's the the way it's gone it's gone
because
it doesn't work against the bad guys who
are just faster
and better than a hard-coded solution
so you have to move into dynamic
profiling
and automatic creation
and you have too much data you can
handle as a human being so you need to
build systems to handle it and that
leads naturally to machine learning and
ai
for both detection and triage and
defense and protection
uh it's just the natural evolution in
order to survive and be relevant in this
cat and mouse
type of uh field
by the way it's also happening in
medical care
that was an era where you take a doctor
with 30 years of experience
and that read 10 000
pages in books over his life her life
and you find out that
one ai model is able to run on more
cases and read more pages of knowledge
than any doctor can do on the planet
and
that machine can apparently find do a
better job
identifying 99 of the
images
and symptoms and what have you so again
in the cat and mouse of fighting
diseases or fighting
uh crime
um it's the only way to do it in scale
and efficiently so i truly believe that
and i see it i've seen it in my journey
and i sit in with license every day with
the customers we work with
now with the
companies that you're running you know
what something that they have in common
is that they're enablers for other
companies to take ownership of their
processes
you know work better understand the
world better and and take whatever
offering they have and and be able to to
serve it in in the most meaningful way
and not be you know
taken back by decisions and by the lack
of knowledge
where is the next leap in your eyes
in what businesses around the world need
in order to become better so right now
you're you're doing perhaps one of the
most critical things which is this the
data the data question
what what is left you know to help
optimize
wow
everything
can be optimized everything can be
optimized you see it every day
and you have some cutting-edge companies
are ahead of the market and the market
will take 20 years to follow
but think about the recommendation
systems around you think about the
automatic healthcare system
in some places think about covered
accelerating remote learning that can be
totally disruptive think about what
tesla is doing and how our
transportation systems will totally
change think about
every experience in our life can be
optimized
and that optimization will result in
interesting things right it'll be
higher quality care education
entertainment etc
more free time
you have to feel that free time with
something because
you know people don't want to be bored
jobs will change
so that evolution has been going on for
you know tens of thousands of years from
the invention of the wheel
but it's accelerating and it's impacting
now every day of our life i see it
you know i have a ring that tracks my
sleep and tells me how you can sleep
better i would have never thought
someone would invent a ring that tells
me how you can sleep better but that's
happening right now and that's a
everyday usage i'm on the board of a
company using ai an iot
company called ava swiss company to help
women get pregnant without the use of
uh you know intrusive techniques
or uh other treatments
and it's amazingly accurate over 30 000
babies were born
thanks to that ai
that personalizes the medical care and
the recommendation system to a single
individual versus a generic healthcare
system dealing with averages and
you know generic treatments so i think
our entire life is being
evolved in front of our eyes
incredible
not every day that i get to speak to
somebody who wakes up and is leading a
ship of a thousand people uh
what is that like what what concerns you
as a leader because before we're geeking
out about commodore 65 or 64. you see
i'm too young to even know the number
yeah and we're geeking out about it but
you know
there is no 65.
there is no 65 itself of course
but
we're talking about the baghzalim right
the the core piece of it and all of a
sudden now you're leading this crazy
ship
and
how how is it what do you have to
concern yourself with
you know what you find that the hardware
is really important but the wet wear as
they call it the humans around it are
more important
and as you scale accompany the
challenges around culture
around global teams
during covet about culture drift which
is a real risk as you scale in a in a
virtual reality
they need to focus more and more teams
and align them they need to empower
uh but still be very very um
aligned operationally
those are all real challenges and
they're actually more complex than
technology because you deal with humans
uh versus robots you get the advantage
of that which is innovation
and thinking outside the box
and many other things but you get the
disadvantages that
you know humans are very different from
each other and
helping the large team unite is hard
work
it's hard work right
is it
do you feel like you have a grasp
on you know what's happening in a
thousand person company imagine when
you're leading a team
or when you're leading even you know two
dozen people you sort of know what's
happening you know who's that what was
everybody doing and now i can't imagine
that you can even keep track of a third
of what's happening in the company and
sort of your role is now to guide
everybody and empower everybody to be
their own micro leaders right
yeah um
first you cannot do it you need to rely
on a very strong leadership team
second my personal style and it does
make it the correct style purely my
personal style is
to
understand the details in a in a sampled
way right representative way in order to
build the mental image in my head of
what's going on
other people don't do that they they
you know do it more high level i like to
connect the details to the high level it
helps me understand and
really understand what's going on
you never truly know what's going on
right it's only a
mental model you build of what's going
on
but
i believe in a very accessible
leadership style that
allows people and customers and
prospects
to talk to me more than other people i
find it helpful for me
and that's how i stay connected with
reality
um but versus you know what i learned
over the two last 20 years 25 years
there's no one way to lead there's no
one way to manage there's no one correct
ceo style
companies are built around the specific
profile of the people and the leaders in
them
and many different styles can work
as successfully at the end
and that took me some time to understand
i thought there is some ideal perfect
way to do it there isn't
right inspiration
where do you get that from you have to
continuously innovate involve inspire
others to be their best where do you get
your own personal inspiration
number one family
end of day uh
my wife is probably my best role model
uh she's amazing
she's built by the way two startups and
two non-profits so i'm i'm behind
everyone
so um
home and the ability to disconnect and
be at home um
you know and do that switching between
the modes
i still play computer games i love it
you know different uh strategy games
civilization and the like allows me to
disconnect and go and build some cities
um
i live
going out and just enjoying life you
know rock concerts are back now we've
covered i literally bought you know
almost 12 tickets or 12 different shows
i'm going to point to in the next few
months
high energy
i came to tel aviv we had guns and roses
just before coffee hit i think uh it was
just before kobe did
so yeah um
you know
i love it live hard and work out not
just one or two of the two
what 100 and i and i hope to see you at
billy joel's concert in madison square
garden it will be a dream come true for
me
but no but but really amir thank you so
much for for this time and for for the
inspiration and you know for the
authenticity behind you know the
geekiness behind the passion to create
impact uh the intentionality with which
you lead and with which you innovate and
run businesses the the egoless approach
of saying you know what it doesn't have
to be my own idea as long as i love the
idea i can put myself on the title aside
and i can come in and and be a part of
the team and and obviously time and time
again you're taking these businesses and
and where they where you left them is
not where
you came in and and so just thank you
for the for this time and how busy you
are and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you same for you